Yeah,
well,
you know,
the dod is a huge bureaucracy and we
have a culture where the,
it's called a Gotcha culture where,
you know,
anytime a bureaucrat makes a mistake,
the line is shot,
light shines on them and Congress
investigates them and the General
Accountability Office goes after them.
And so there's this tremendous risk
aversion.
So you see government doing two things.
First,
if you have a look at a government
document,
it's always in the passive verb,
a verb form.
Things have happened,
mistakes were made.
Who made them?
Oh,
I don't know who made them.
They were made because that way no one
has accountability and responsibility.
If people were given a little more slack
to make mistakes,
then they would probably be a lot more
accountable.
Well,
take it to the next level.
Do you want to reform anything?
Reformed means change.
Reform Means Dynamo.
Dynamism reform means that you might be
looked at in a way that you know,
and before you could hide under,
behind some piece of paper.
So the bureaucracy hates reform.
When Rumsfeld came in,
uh,
he wanted to transform the Pentagon and
one of the things he did was ask me to
change the way we handled our financial
management because nobody paid much
attention to it.
Well,
one of the things I found was the people
who work in that area where themselves
so dismissive of their work that they
were nine to fivers,
they'd given up.
It was almost like,
well,
if they were working there,
it's probably because they weren't good
enough and it wasn't true.
Some of them were very,
very good.
Um,
we made some changes.
For instance,
we had a problem that,
uh,
we couldn't account for all our
transactions.
Sometimes there was a zip code wrong,
whatever it might be,
but it didn't fit to the point of two
and a half trillion dollars.
That's a lot of transactions that
couldn't be accounted for.
I started a process.
Now I think the problem isn't measured
in a few millions.
So we got rid of 99.9%
of the problem.
It took a lot of dedicated people to do
that,
but all of a sudden they felt that,
you know,
I was paying attention to them as
undersecretary,
but more important,
the secretary of defense cared about
what they were doing and for bureaucrat
to recognize,
it's not that somebody wants to
criticize them,
but somebody cares about what they're
doing.
They're going to respond differently.
[inaudible].